that's how I feel with even like Road
gigs is I'm driven 12 hours like dipping
back for a gigs now any other gig I'm
like go eight hours yeah yeah I've done
all that like I risk my life to drive
three ten hours to bomb come back on a
snowy road I'm the only car with ball
tires and its trucks like swerving
because they should even be out there
much miss me mm-hmm
[Music]
all right hot breath averse welcome back
to the hot breath podcast it is I your
host comedian Joel Byers if you do
enjoys today episode today episode which
you will because our guest is one of the
most sought-after comedy writers in the
game please all we ask like share
subscribe share this with your other
comedian brethren and sistren share this
with people you know that love comedy
and love learning because this one today
is going to be a masterclass on comedy
writing and also following your instinct
in this game my guest today
his comedy career actually started in
the Burger King drive-thru where he
would tell jokes to customers until one
day a customer is like hey you should
try comedy and the rest is history he is
now one of the highly demanded comedy
writers he's written on SNL 2 Broke
Girls
blackish just to name a few but all that
success did not come without the comedy
grind he had in New York City living in
his car that had holes in it I believe
had holes in the floor yeah your car too
now becoming where he is but what I mean
while him following his instinct is he's
been in all these great writers rooms
and all these great comedy stages but he
actually quit 2 Broke Girls to then
write for blackish - then quit so he
could pursue stand-up full-time all the
way to the extent that he actually
turned down another TV writing gig on
lil rel show so he could actually pursue
the craft of stand-up even more so he is
now coming out with a special July 11th
12 12th July 12th so sorry I need to do
my research but you're definitely going
to want to take notes on this one
tune in turn up that is not our
catchphrase but today it is so ladies
and gentleman welcome to the hot breath
averse mr. Ian Edwards everyone what's
up Joe why am I even here you just told
them everything you know I told him the
coat you need see now now they know I
used to try to like weave in my research
into conversation but I've learned that
if I just get it out all up front right
now the audience has context for all
this education you have is I only lived
in my car for like three months
living in your car at all man yeah well
you make it sound so easy
it was easy yeah yeah what was the worst
of it like where do you eat where do you
shower slept in a Pathmark parking lot
as a 24-hour supermarket in a in New
York mm-hmm so there's people coming in
and out and turn on the car for heat and
I had a friend in the back seat he was
homeless - what he got into it with his
parents - so he wasn't he wasn't state
so and then I dropped him off at Nassau
Community College because he went there
and he shower there and I would go to
another friend's house and shower and
then food used I'm never home anyways
you just eat the food you know you go
out and get you know food okay with what
money if you're living in a car it
doesn't mean you broke just means you
don't have a place to live I just can't
afford a place to live okay because I
just I just like got into it with my
parents and then left home
that's that [ __ ] I'll just stay in my
car - the final spot it worked out yeah
yeah it's just all while you're doing
stand-up yeah like in New York New York
uh-huh yeah so what I what I would like
to even dive into is I I did learn in
researching you you talked about like
studying comedians while in New York and
like seeing someone like Chris Rock work
out a bit from just saying it or reading
it to now it's seeing it on a special
way and you you talked about being able
to watch a comedian and the right way to
actually study them and we mean learn to
community the right way well you would
watch like a Richard Pryor and like Bill
Cosby and actually studying their moves
as opposed to just listening for the
joke you're actually studying how
they're funny
well you just pick up things from him
like I got look at Richard Pryor and the
first thing that stuck out to me more
than anything was originality and I was
like how I is the original arms because
he's talking about his life and then
that led to me thinking that you know
realizing probably for the first time or
the early age that every person is an
individual
and we've all been through even though
we're all human and we're all connected
we're all the same that we're all
different and then if you bring the
different parts of you onstage then you
won't be sound like everybody else so so
that gave me that you know watching
Richard Pryor because I can't do
characters like he can but I can be
myself like he he was and so rich
watching which part taught me that also
watching Richard Pryor and Bill Cosby
taught me good storytelling and
structure mm-hmm and then I'd watch
other comics and I see that they'd have
one-liners and then it was easy for me
to write one line is at first too like
you just get a sentence like or like if
somebody like there were comics that
would like turn facts into jokes like I
had a like so I just started trying to
gather the facts at first like like one
fact was like most car accidents happen
within 10 miles of your home and I'll be
like I haven't been in an accident in
years I just parked 20 miles from home
you just figure out a way uh you know
like that but then you're like [ __ ] how
many one-liners I need 50 one-liners
right but then I realized oh you just
take the topics and keep tagging them
you know what I mean you just keep
tagging them and then so like I have a
shark attack joke that was just it's a
bit if you say it's a bit but it was
just one line at first hmm
so then I realized let me just this is
more meat on the bone just circle around
it study look at it and what other
thoughts come to my head from looking at
this one line or this one fact oh let me
find out some more [ __ ] about sharks let
me let me let me watch the whole story
on the news and find out more about the
story so the girls press conference so
they're not kind of made jokes about the
press conference and then how I feel
about what what what I would do if I was
her what my
action would be and then you just then
it becomes a bit do you have a formula
for surveying a topic where you're like
okay let me hit it from the girls angle
let me explore it from my angle maybe
the news's angle like you have almost
like a checklist you go through and
doing that no like I even like sometimes
I turn a tweet into a bit okay so then I
just sometimes you just come up with a
joke sometimes you see the topic and
then you and you figure out the joke you
know what I mean but once you figure out
the joke you keep looking research the
topic one some more you can Google store
for some some words that you'll read a
word in a paragraph and that stands out
and is like let me find more the meaning
of that word and then you just keep
digging and then more [ __ ] comes out and
then sometimes if I want to write a joke
about a topic
I'll just vomit I'll just let's write
anything that comes out of my just don't
even think about it just write anything
that comes out about it and then in
there will be something you clear out or
be something and then then you do it
again on that something it there's
something and you just had to come up
with a bunch of [ __ ] and is that
something a phrase or a single word
phrase word anything yeah could be a
slang word you know I have a joke about
[ __ ] boy you know he's just a slang word
you know and I just thought about how
different that word meant something else
when I was a kid but when I was younger
and what it means now and I'm going it
made a joke about that and it's in a
special yeah yeah ain't cool it's a
whole bit but it grew from you just free
writing about [ __ ] boy finding some
funny things what I was referring it as
a matter fact I was riffing with
Jermaine Fowler like somebody had called
him [ __ ] boy in a tweet oh and then he
he we were at Westside comedy club in
the green room and he read that off and
in it then that just came out and what
will you take note when things pop up
how do you sometimes yeah I write stuff
in my phone so I don't forget it like I
used to think I remember every
after years of not write down anything
not having new material because I would
write down everything or you you can
make the voice record message to
yourself now I have this thing where I
just text to myself I'll do that too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you'll do
free writing are there any other
techniques you'll use in writing there's
yeah I'll use all the techniques I'll
stand in the mirror and go over [ __ ] and
then because you just by yourself you're
free to improvise you're not waiting for
an audience to tell you that the joke is
done so you'll go further than you
normally would in front of a bunch of
people at least I do sit down and write
with either a pen or type conversations
like when I first started when you
mentioned about the Burger King thing
mm-hmm
when I first saw once I decided I was
gonna do stand-up I realized who am I
gonna get material from so anything that
I would say to somebody that was funny
and they would laugh I'd write that down
make a note of that and get to use as a
joke you know what I mean and then start
gathering material like that like I
didn't want to waste anything any idea
and then sometimes also when you're in
the middle of doing nothing like taking
a shower washing your car or just doing
like a task material or the fix for a
joke the patch for a joke would come and
then yeah stuff will happen should I
write it down right what is a success
rate for a joke I've any of you comments
on here who say like one out of twenty
jokes they'll end up keeping yeah yeah I
have no idea yeah yeah I don't do math
like that Oh No who has time for that
but you through how long you been doing
comedy it's like I don't know if you
just had just sort of like a mental note
of like well I know it's gonna require
me to right now because amount because
jokes each joke is different like
there's jokes I can't I couldn't pull
off back then that I could pull off now
I don't know why
see it's like sometimes you have to be
mature enough or grow a little bit to do
certain moves it's just like sports like
like who is talking about Michael Jordan
was talking about he practiced Duncan
couldn't dunk and then in the middle of
a game
he just [ __ ] dunked and then from
then on he could dunk
you know what I mean but he couldn't
dunk the day before whoa you know what I
mean yeah yeah just in the game it just
happened and it just and then from then
on he could just dunk so it's like the
time has timing yeah I've heard you say
that it took you ten years in comedy to
like really lose the nerves maybe even
longer but yeah Wow at least that but
that's just I just wasn't used to
talking in front of people yeah I'm nine
years in and it's like I'm still like
just really crawling like I mean I feel
funny but then when I look at people
like you have been in the game even
longer it's like there's just so much
more don't measure
I don't ever measure either yeah
measuring is wrong is like huh like you
said this is a comedy class right I this
is what comics do and this is what I did
we open think things we get in our head
and we we make this game harder on
ourselves than it is you know
just know if you first start you're
gonna be terrible and except that you
know some people won't be but a lot of
people will be so this accept that and
that you're gonna don't beat yourself up
every set just you'll get better if you
do the main thing I would tell people is
right before you set listen to your set
afterwards and then work on it after you
know when you listen to you set see what
works see what didn't work see how
emotionally did he's joke because I go
through things on stage when I tell
jokes like I'm like [ __ ] they didn't
laugh at the last one is loud as I
wanted to
so then that might affect how I tell the
other joke so then then I have to be
like just get out of your head
be sudden there's moments in the set
where I'm in different moods and what
I'm listening to the set I have to take
that into consideration hmm and and how
it affected the joke and I maybe I put
myself back in a confident mode [ __ ] it
just do your [ __ ] and then the rest of
the jokes work so it's like like pay
attention to everything don't just like
make emotional decisions and don't get
into your head too much and then just
put in the work before the set putting
the work after the set and you'll I
think you'll get funnier faster you know
what I mean by spending more time with
the material and it'll teach you who you
are faster because you're paying
attention and just don't overthink it
yeah that's what I've learned in I know
you're gonna be inconsistent
that's a frustrating thing that's a
growth thing okay like so even if you
kill and then the same set doesn't work
and it's like who the people you in
front of you know the audience matters
sometimes you know like some people
might not be into that type of [ __ ] and
you have to just keep going until you
get funny enough to it it mostly is
stuff or you have enough material that
you can do these jokes for this crowd
and do these jokes for that crowd so
it's just a growth process but do you
make sure your jokes will work cuz like
I'll do rooms where there's all white
people and all black people and I don't
want my jokes to work in both yeah yeah
we are you talking about like tailoring
jokes to a room is that what you mean
nah but okay if I'm in Atlantic City and
and a lot of crowds like if you live
Factory in Atlantic City
okay the all the hair on the audience is
white so I don't think they want to hear
a squirting joke so you might have to
cut that out but some people don't have
a joke replacement for their squirting
joke
they're only been doing it a few years
right if you've been doing it awhile as
I'll do this joke that I don't usually
do anymore or it's or I do do but I
wasn't gonna do it tonight I'll just do
it now
gotcha yeah okay yeah 'la we're nosov
the audience yeah and being fair to them
they're not pandering but like yeah
they're not gonna want some joke that
you wrote in any way that you like
mm-hmm but you just wasn't gonna do that
night you you just you can do it yeah
and that process learning that process
can require a lot of bombing yeah what
we I feel like every comedian I always
ask all the comics like their most
memorable bombing or like getting booed
on stage or like is there one that pops
out into your mind that's just like
unforgettable yeah there's a lot of them
but one like talk about growing like
when I started in New York I just wanted
a strong five minutes and then I got
that strong five minutes and I'm from
Jamaica so that material was about me
being Jamaican he's a lot of Jamaicans
in New York it used to kill like from
beginning to end and then you'd like
start getting respect in spots and stuff
like that and then I got booked on a
show in Philly you know a Temple
University with some other comics and
then I go out I do my first joke and
that [ __ ] bombed because there's no
Jamaicans hmm in Philly and then my next
joke is about being Jamaican so it's
just like a thousand people staring at
me like what the [ __ ] is this dude
talking about right we don't know any
Jamaicans don't have any contact or
context and the third joke and then they
start they throw this must be like five
hundred four thousand people that booed
me whoa yeah which is why like like but
it makes you tough of course makes you
tough course and sometimes on Twitter
like I made this video on my Instagram
about a
Ruiz losing that fight as a boxer he
breeds one he beat Anthony Joshua mm-hmm
and I made a video like kind of input in
my post and my post I gave you Ruiz he's
out of shape guy and he beat this the
most in-shape guy ever and I made I gave
him his props but in the video I still
kind of clown his shape
you know because it's like him being out
of shape is the outstanding thing about
the fight about him winning the fight
you know what I mean yeah so you know
there's jokes in that so then I posted
it and then all things comedy reposted
but they they changed the caption to
suit you know you know because they were
posting it so then people don't see the
part where I praised Ruiz and they start
trying to [ __ ] on the video right and
I'm like hey man I don't either way I
don't care I've been booed a room of 500
people to a thousand people told me I
wasn't funny and I didn't listen to them
so no matter what you say to me you
write your cute insult on Instagram or
Twitter why would I listen to you like
I'm immune mmm-hmm you know so that's
how I feel with even like rode gigs is
I'm driven 12 hours like you've been
back for a gigs now any other gig I'm
like you hang go eight hours yeah yeah I
don't know all that
like I yeah risk my life to drive three
ten hours to bomb come back on a snowy
road I'm the only car with ball tires
and it's trucks like swerving because
they shouldn't even be out there much
less me mmm it's like good luck Twitter
didn't even exist in good luck y'all
wasting your time trying to discourage
me that's what we like we're just we're
masochist man not even masochist I just
feel like we know what we want to do I
know what I want to do you
so let you fix the camera we'll see the
Edit afterwards yeah yeah this is a
one-man band right here this is this is
the hustle man fure yeah we've done this
over 180 this week was a 180 that we
just watched so it was we had a we had
en bag on this one for 180 and he was
talking about driving five hours for
five minutes you know like yeah just the
stuff we do yeah so what what stuck out
to me when you're talking out that ruies
mm-hmm
situation was that you you almost like
had a clear premise you're like it's
funny because he's out of shape right
you [ __ ] do you look for that in a joke
we were like okay if it has a clear
premise then I know I'm onto something
yeah yeah I mean or sometimes I used to
only write jokes cuz write jokes from
write bits from a joke that I saw
immediately but now then I'm mature to
the point where this is an interesting
topic I want to have a joke about this
topic so let me sit down and figure it
out because when you first start doing
comedy like you've just learning how to
write jokes so you might not necessarily
be talking about the things you want to
talk about and this is just you know for
me specifically but then I learned that
joke writing formulas just from trying
to just have material you just get it
from anywhere you just learn how to
write jokes and then you start applying
it to personal [ __ ] because now you know
the formulas you have experience and now
you can write more about the things that
you want to write about as opposed to
just waiting for things to fall out the
sky that that appeal to you that are
funny so well what are some of those
formulas just misdirection and okay you
know just the same thing about you know
the the car
you know the accidents from home like
the surprise I did
it's just things you can do like even
when I'm texting with people I take a
second before I respond I was like
somebody's might say hi or good morning
and there's there's a if you think for a
minute there's a way you can respond to
it sometimes I'll wait five hours to
respond to a good-morning text and it'll
be five and afternoon and then I'll
write back good morning you know what I
mean just because just because because
five pm good morning it's funny and 10
a.m.
good morning back you know I mean I love
your commitment to the craft yeah you
just have to go back to sleep that's all
it is and wake about five hours later or
seven whatever the time is yeah I
started I actually started with
one-liners as well right and like how I
would do a one-liner is I would like
have a set up I've explored topics to
create a set up and this was all like
more surface jokes just like figuring
how to be funny you know before even
getting personal but I would like have a
set up and then be like okay what all is
the audience assuming what am i setting
them up to think and then pick one of
those assumptions and then like flip it
and that would be the punchline right is
that how you would kind of dissect a
one-liner or how would you and I get
from point A to point B like similar
like that misdirection say something
shocking or just flip or twist like this
is a flip or twist to anything you know
and then you just look for it and or
there's the the thing in the sentence
that nobody's focused on but if you make
the joke about the thing so it's like
this you have the sentence that has this
important thing but there's this one
thing in it that nobody's paying
attention to and if you mention that
thing the joke is that thing because
everybody is faith is looking at the end
of the sentence where you know you
almost have to direct their attention to
the end of the sentence well direct
attention there automatically goes
towards like the most important thing in
the sentence okay so you could make a
joke about the least important thing
innocent
I could say don't expect it to them boom
you know so you have an example a
personal example right now yeah it's
fine yeah yeah I was trying to think of
one as well but I think maybe like my my
I talked about how Harriet Tubman I I
talk about news and how Harriet Tubman
the only good news that had recently was
Harriet Tubman was the is gonna be the
first woman on a $20 bill and then
everybody applauds that's a very
important statement but then I checked
out a picture of Harriet Tubman and it
looks like there's still gonna be a dude
on the $20 bill you know what I mean I
you start looking at other things
uh-huh yeah gotcha yes and it's like a
simple thing about her mm-hmm and then
nobody would ever really insult Harriet
Tubman but if I saw her then I can
insult any race about anything because
I've attacked to one of my own right
yeah so I'm fear yeah you have that joke
about a you know Jesse Jackson's you
don't want to butcher the joke it's like
don't butcher I love like anytime it
could be and then the Kamiya has to
correct you like verbatim no it's
actually this but but yeah he's not a
good leader because he hasn't ever been
like nobody ever tried to kill him yeah
yeah like how did had it been that I was
listening down the way here actually to
how did how did that joke kind of bloom
into like a funny bit from like a
thought I don't even remember that's the
things like okay the funny thing about
some of these jokes is I don't always
remember they're a rich installer
because they start from such a place
sometime and then you you work with them
and they didn't become something and
then you just know how to Sam and then
you don't remember what you kind of went
through to get to that point you know
and then some of them I do and some of
them I don't some of them
yeah something about doing some of them
I don't to be honest yeah so that one
just kind of popped in your head in
there well this statement I know pissed
me off when like like I just felt like
as black people were just like so tell
that joke took years not because I tried
to write it for years but just watching
Jesse Jackson on the news for years oh
and what white people thought about him
and what black people thought about him
and then you know through comedy
maturity it just hit me with the thought
hit me one day you know what I mean so
it's been bacon subconsciously for a
long time yeah and I heard George Carlin
say that a lot of his jokes he would
like think them and then just let him
tumble around and his subconscious for
however long it took come back to later
on yeah because that's you had the
example that he was standing next to
Martin Luther King yeah if they do that
a clear shot at him too and he just
packed up his rifle and went home yeah
it's I said even an evening Jesse
Jackson Ben I mean even Al Sharpton been
stabbed yeah yeah and you say I'll shark
gonna be like if white people had Hulk
Hogan yeah yeah yeah that's what it's
like having Jesse out Sharpton as your
leader is if white people had a hawk
Hogan as your leader your racial leader
how would you like that because they
feel like these leaders were appointed
by white people for black people's ID
and choose these people
yeah what if I gave you Hulk Hogan as
your racial league yeah and it's funny I
like you saying the Jesse Jackson thing
it pissed you off so there was like an
emotional interest in the joke yeah
that's probably why it had because I
felt at one time Jesse Jackson was a
good leader but the last few decades
it's all about the money and then I know
some people that worked for him too and
they confirmed it and it's like this is
this is a sham now this guy's yeah so I
can't stand behind that then you can
make it a funny bit yeah and it boom
yeah and just get my little opinion out
there yeah you could tackle these topics
and I think it is important like for
comedians to like have be interested in
your material but like starting out is
it just about learning how to make
anything funny or would you recommend
like comedians starting out to start
from like what are you interested in and
build from there I feel like people can
just do whatever they want there's no
there's no one way to do it you know but
at first I just wanted to have material
for me you know so that anything that I
thought was funny and to be honest I
haven't really changed that much
material wise you know what I mean
it's either something personal something
social some still a silly you know like
a combination of the three things that
maybe there's more but that's all I can
think of right now and you were a tag
machine like watching you here in
Atlanta this weekend but then also just
being a fan and watching you it's just
you will beat a bit to death you'll just
tag tag tag tag tag tag like how it's
it's almost overwhelming we're like wait
he's still going and then you're like
okay there's okay he could end it here
and then you build on it again how do
you know when a bit is done just
performing it over a period of time let
you let you know I didn't that's another
thing like I told myself I realized one
time like when I thought I had jokes
that were done I'm like who says this is
done like if I say it's done it's done
but if I leave it open
I can always come up with some so even
if I have a bit that's full like I still
say it's never done it's never done
until you shoot it and it's special and
then you can't use it anymore
yeah yeah yeah and when you return out
turning one-liners into stories link
into bits yeah yeah how is it how were
you able to like kind of stretch it out
and because you just because the one
line is a one-liner but it's also a
topic so what else is funny about this
topic so then you can look up the topic
or just write down funny things about
the topic and then then you start like
growing it you know that's you and then
you put one part there one part and you
make it you you you you put it in an
order that that a beginning middle end
of a bit you know what I mean it's like
a story yeah it's kind of it's gonna
have like we start here and we end here
yeah and do you like your bits kind of
like in a sketch like there'd be like an
arc like an emotional arc or like a
story arc within your jokes if one
happens yeah
you don't overthink it to wear it but
it's got it in here right yeah okay yeah
how does it compare to like you riding
on all these like amazing TV shows
because that's that's why you got out of
it also because it was taking away from
stand-up and I like him I'm funny on
stage too right
and you you but I was doing both you've
always been doing both always both but
then the industry just sees you as a
writer even though you don't both like
I'm performing all the time in LA like
at the laughs at the improv in the
Comedy Store yeah so then they don't see
as a comic and then friends they're on
the road they're free or they have more
time they're making more money than in
the writers room even though you know so
that they you know I'd rather do that
and be free and travel and see the world
and have even more of my own schedule I
mean the writer writers rooms will pay
do a little rel you said it was like it
would have been 9 grand a week yeah like
I'm at The Comedy Store where like Theo
von is going to Australia and selling
like thousands out Tom Segura Rogen and
and I'm definitely not at that level I'm
losing money right now but like I could
I couldn't see and it anything that I've
set my mind to I've done so I'll just
keep going and stand up and do that yeah
and a special coming out yeah that'll
help you know I'm trying to get the
material together to do another one
already yeah yeah like half the material
in the set you saw last night is new and
the half of it is from the special which
has an aired yet and I'm just trying to
keep writing and push the last half out
like the set that I'm doing now it's
it's the best mediocre set I can do
because everything is not cooked and
bait right yeah yeah and we get the best
of my mediocrity
we're time out you're writing a new set
like do you sit down and write every day
are you talking the mirror everyday like
are you discipline like that uh there's
times when I am and there's times when I
when I'm not mm-hmm but uh like when I
say about comedy is simple it's like
think of it like this if you write if
you sit down to write you know I used to
like try to write whole bits and and
it's frustrating if you have a writing
session with yourself or whatever if you
have people with you it's frustrating
when you don't come up with a whole
thing but here's how I simplify comedy
it's like if you write a new tag or a
new joke every day or a new joke or a
tag to a existing joke every day right
there's 365 days in a year
by the end of the year you'll have 365
funny things mmm
so then people don't beat yourself up
you know just when you sit down the
right come up with one funny thing you
can keep going and come up with more but
don't be disappointed that you didn't
write the world's greatest bit in one
session
right yeah you may write ten sessions
and not have anything and then that
eleventh is like oh I just found three
things right oh yeah or you know if you
get one yeah it's just but you know just
just do it sit down and do it right yeah
yeah I think one of my favorite writing
quotes is Chris Titus said he hates
writing but loves having written all
right look you always feel better after
right but it's showing up yeah it's like
ah but then someone like mark Normand he
talked about on here he'll just talk for
an hour so he's more of just vocal he'll
just talk to himself just talk to
himself about whatever the topics are
right and then pull bits from that right
that makes sense yeah I feel like an
insane person if I'm staying at home
just talking
it's like talking in the mirror doing
talking you know like if your writing is
talking that's all it is but with a pen
you know you're having a conversation
like like I say I get jokes from having
conversations with people yeah you know
it's like if you have nobody to bounce
it off you just that's why sometimes
I'll just bounce an idea off a cop
just to have something you know to come
up with something you know what I mean
yeah it's we're always looking for jokes
but it's like is there is there like a
trigger where you're like this is worth
pursuing and not just because we'll be
this is hilarious and then as soon as
you're saying it on stage you're like
this is the dumbest thing I've ever
thought like in the middle of a sentence
I'll just be like I don't even know why
I'm gonna finish this sentence this is
dumb I mean sometimes it's it's like
that just and then sometimes it isn't it
just is what it is I mean the beauty is
that you know this is dumb that means
you've learned comedy right you know
what I mean and you know better as
opposed to the person that doesn't know
because you've seen the comics that
don't know what isn't what isn't funny
and they keep doing it and then that
that's a learning curve deficiency you
know what I mean so knowing what's not
funny
is a it's a marker comedy yeah I'll take
that yeah I'll take that perspective
yeah so with with you jumping into
stand-up and you're really getting into
your special because it's it's it's a
unique format you're going for here and
like it's with all these specials coming
out
saturating the market mm-hmm we're at a
point where even someone at your level
of funny is like me being like knock out
funny just isn't enough right right so
like what what was your kind of approach
to you can tell people what the special
is as much as you want I'll wait and
I'll release this when the special comes
out as well though just what's all in
the same time so if you want to say
anything about it then as if it's
already out but like how many ideas did
you go through before you landed on this
one or like what made you decide on this
like what was whole top process around
me standing and just being funny is not
the move on this one well I just wanted
to maximize everything okay and I wanted
to there's so many specials so
definitely wanted to do one that got
people's attention more than just a
regular special so I just chose like a
you know I just thought it would be
funny to do it as a TED talk and talk
about things that they would never allow
me to do on a TED talk so it's just like
just added another layer of funny to
what's already there you know so you
know just being standing up there with
the whole set up and being a efficient
audio on [ __ ] like talking about
hose you know thing in the background oh
yeah yeah with a screen in the
background and you know just doing it
that way what made you think of that or
other ideas or you just came to you yeah
just came to me yeah okay and then when
I started telling people like burn those
people they're like that they're like
yeah and our magical czar yeah that's
funny you know because Birds producing
it right yeah yeah Birds producing it
all things comedy our magical bird yeah
yeah that's so cool that like all things
comedy is like this grassroots Comedy
Network that is now like someone like
Comedy Central is like hey will you come
here common sense you want to buy this
oh yeah yeah oh I think I did yeah a few
people wanted to buy them
I don't see why not with people like
Bill burr and how magical behind like at
the helm you know it's kind of that
seems to be where the industry is headed
though or the industry is where it is
kind of like people just making having
self-made success and then all like all
like the networks are trying to just
latch on are you seeing that yeah that's
what comedy is anyways like it's like
like if you go back to Dane Cook all
right like Dane was doing comedy for a
while he was killing all right and and
it wasn't until like he went into some
meeting and went on the computer and
logged into his I love it was his face
because Instant Messenger at the time it
was my he was on myspace Mattel he blew
up yeah yeah but but people logged in he
had a meeting where I don't think it was
even myspace at the time was like maybe
it was messenger on myspace boy he was
login and all these people would like
start talking to him and then the agency
or the studio whatever he was saw like
oh [ __ ] and it's like you know you know
you're gonna give Dana special and
movies because he has these millions of
fans and you want those fans to come to
your network so you give him a show and
then so that's what comics are doing
like they're doing their podcasts and
they're building like Marc Maron was
dead in the water
you know he'll tell you and then he
started the podcast and all of a sudden
because of his subscription the amount
of people that like subscribe to him and
was listening to his podcast he has
gayben value and then all the big people
come in they give him a TV show alright
you know what I mean then you know and
now he's on that TV show's over he's on
another TV show like he probably could
have auditioned for was like the
wrestling what's a female wrestling glow
glow thing on Netflix yeah a Peter or
he's a good actor he's killing it on
there but he might audition for that as
Marc Maron without the podcast and
without the TV show before and they gave
it to somebody else
with more credits but because he's Marc
Maron and he has credits and he's also
good because sometimes in Hollywood you
could kill a role but now it's like
we'll give it to this other person who
if it's a tie in the audition room
they're gonna give it to the person most
likely with the more credits
ya know you know so all the [ __ ] helps
like to to to build your own thing and
it's promising for especially comedians
I love being a comedian because it's
like we were like a Swiss Army knife in
a sense where we are the writer editor
director actor you know edit my podcast
I find the clips on it the post online
and I posted it after I posted after I
shoot it and I post the audio in the
video on Monday night you do you do all
that yeah but I go into all things
comedy to record and record it then they
sent me to the audio link and the video
link and then do it take it from there
Wow yeah yeah I mean here it's all get
all you saw yeah yeah yeah you should
just only have to write jokes now you
got to be on Twitter by the post a post
on Instagram then have your podcast put
the [ __ ] on YouTube as I its this is not
the lazy job I was hoping it with I
thought I was gonna be sleeping oh no
this is a job it's like the show is a
job but then the business is also yeah a
job mm-hmm
so with creating your own like success
and I've this is I mean I've thought you
know I have ideas for like a pilot but
ideas are a dream until you put them to
work you know so it's like in putting
together like a writer's packet that
you're so versed in and to maybe pitch
to people or just to have if someone's
like hey I'm so-and-so what else you got
cuz it's never enough just to be a
stand-up like what else you got it's
like if you have a writer's packet what
all goes into a writer's packet
but well that's kind of like a confusing
question like a writer's packet like
like what do you mean well when you when
you apply for writing jobs using them a
writer's packet right well I send them
what they asked for and every show
depending on the type of show acts with
different things okay so if it's a
sketch show you know then before I used
to do a lot of sketch show so I had
sketches some that I wrote to apply for
the job and some that I had written that
I was paid to write for other sketch
shows so whether they use them or not
that goes into the sketch package okay
Wow
so always had a sketch package for a
show and if it's a variety show like a
late-night talk show
I used to write up-to-date Twitter jokes
that were political and stuff so if that
you know like say late a new late-night
talk show happens they they send you all
bless you thank you they send you a list
of what they want they like one
monologue jokes des pieces okay sketches
you know whatever they ask for like
they're actually for for different types
of things so then I just go to my
Twitter get the 10 latest jokes from
there that would be my monologue you
know and and so I wouldn't have to write
the monologue I like that that part will
be taken care of then you know got a
desk then I have to create desk pieces I
desk piece
ideas based on their specifications and
you know then the other segments I'd
have to create stuff based on whatever
they ass and then maybe there's I'd have
stuff from another package that I sent
in that I could still repurpose or reuse
in that so and then for a sitcom you
know they want to see a sample of like
pilot that you wrote or a sample of
another show that was on the air that
you wrote and it had to be like back
then you had to think there was shows
that were hot then they wanted to see a
sample of
specific shows so you had to like okay
so by like when Seinfeld was hot they
wanted to see your Seinfeld spec and
then they want to see a curvy enthusiasm
spec after that and then now I think
it's more personal [ __ ] like like it's
more you're just a spec of some [ __ ] you
know you could be I know people that
wrote plays and got a sitcom job from or
a movie they submit a movie idea that
they wrote you know okay yeah expect
just means like you wrote for free right
yeah that respect means pretty much okay
so you're also looking you win like
directing school yeah so you're like
you're almost getting away from writing
and you want to become almost like the
puppet master you want to start pulling
more strings in the Ian Edwards
what do you mean brand like if you want
to become a director you want to start
doing movies you're like what is because
what I what I liked about what you said
earlier you said whatever I put my mind
to right I've achieved and I've been
more mindful of that this year in terms
of like setting a high bar and like
actually working towards it and not just
like he'll be fine what is is but like
having a clear vision and having
ambition is something a lot of comics
may lack so it was cool to hear you I
put my mind at things I achieve them
this was like what are you putting your
mind toward right now to building this
road thing into like the good road I
could go somewhere there's a good road
go go in town to a theater you know
instead of doing six or seven shows on a
weekend or just doing some good solid
rock club one-nighters and sell them out
you know and getting the door and
building that into theaters and maybe
more I don't know if I want to do arenas
I think that's just too much have you
done those with Joe Rogan have you done
in the arenas shows we've done we've
done like three thousand seat theaters
and [ __ ] like that
that's like manageable and then oh I
went I did go with Tosh and we did like
some 6,000 seat places
like and then all of it might not have
been full but its tweet even Tosh is
like why the [ __ ] am I doing this it was
so real yeah I don't like haven't you
done this before
but then after you start doing them it
works just like a club the way they set
it up you know so I see why comics like
Kevin Hart ends up doing a football
stadium cuz he grew into it but still if
you just standing on outside looking at
it say I want to do that it's too much
oh it's like overwhelming yeah it's
overwhelming yeah like how do you get
everybody to listen oh right you know
sometimes you sometimes it's people
talking there's people talking the
Laughing Skull is like 90 people are
thinking holes I think maybe the max my
80 or 90 yeah yeah so and you can't
always control everybody in there right
so imagine like 50,000 people in this
football stadium yeah what it like you
perform in front of 80 a laughing school
and it's like when you have that room
rockin like yeah I mean you'll be
buzzing afterwards yeah I can imagine
8,000 you must be on just like straight
drop I mean how high you are after that
set I'm just glad I made it how long
have you worked with Tosh maybe like
four five years yeah he's kind of a
mysterious character in comedy like he's
he has a successful TV show he has
killer specials but he's kind of off he
doesn't do interviews off on his own
yeah yeah yeah what is he like he's just
he's just he's a funny guy he's fun to
be around yeah yeah hilarious yeah likes
to joke around he loves sports
yeah just a fun guy good to have some
good weekends this doing shows and
just clownin yeah he's a comedian he's a
comedian yeah yeah he's not like above
it he's just maybe strategic and how he
presented yeah because like in it it's
like if you do an interview somebody
could use some [ __ ] against you he's
like he's already successful right what
does he need to be he's he's where he
wants to be he's doing exactly what he
wants to do right and he's not being
pulled by the lure of something else you
know what I mean and he's enjoying his
life and living it the way he wants to
live it and that's the thing you just
you know I think he follows his
instincts you know what I mean and
that's what we just need to do that
that's all comedies for first of all if
you were comic you're following your
instincts because you're taking an L
you're taking an L from like you're not
going the traditional trajectory of life
to get what you want you know but you're
being called by your inner self to do
something and you're taking the chance
to do it and you know that you're not
gonna have like the things that society
tells you that you should have like a
job and financial security at first but
you know the promise of it is what you
are listening to in the fulfillment of
it you know what I mean so like while
you're in it don't stop listening to
your instincts and don't get pulled off
course to do some [ __ ] within it that
you really don't want to do you know
what I mean
so following your instincts maybe like
not taking a job just for the sake of
having a job yeah yeah it's almost just
embraced the struggle band on that no
it's not even just not taking a job it's
like like like a simple example one time
I went to this meeting
okay and then the guy gets on the phone
in the middle of a story I'm telling and
he was a meeting with a big agency I
just like I guess one the NBC comedy
competition or something I forgot that
the diversity common right yeah and it's
guys on the phone and because it's a big
agency I stayed to the got off the phone
finished the story which he was paying
attention to anyway I should just left
that [ __ ] meeting once he got on the
phone and walked out my instinct like my
instinct telling me I would have won I
would have got his attention and he
would have gave me the respect and I
would have probably been with that
agency but because I'm like waiting for
some guy to finish the [ __ ] phone
call you called me to come into this
meeting in the first place yeah yeah but
you know yeah I just wanted it so bad I
wasn't listening to this is wrong like
if if I did got on the phone and he was
talking he would have like ended the
meeting so just leave say man I'm you
know I don't have to be leaving a mean
way hey man this is isn't as important
to you as I thought it would be so I'm
out mm-hmm yeah but when it comes to
following your instincts ain't at some
point especially in comedy like I mean
you need money
to like live yeah yeah I've done I've
done it you knew you you'll make us
short-term sacrifice you'll take it
short
yeah the low-hanging fruit just to get
you to a long-term goal yeah yeah okay
yeah okay that's right it but there is a
point when you have to be like no more
low-hanging fruit
or else.you because some people end up
doing that and they go off track it
takes it's like it's like it's like when
you're walking down a path and there's a
so say it's if you stay on the path if
it's five miles to the next Apple right
but on the side of the path there's an
apple tree so you walk up to the apple
tree and you grab an apple you can go
back to the path or there's an orange
tree and you go over to the orange tree
in the abakada tree and then you're ten
miles off the [ __ ] path as a and as
opposed to just you could have gotten to
that five miles
on the path if you know what I mean yeah
yeah he's got to watch out for that but
it's also knowing like you want an apple
tree like it's knowing your vision like
you said whatever you put your mind to
you accomplished it yeah
so as part of that like knowing okay I
know where I want to be in this amount
of time so I'm gonna do whatever it
takes for this man I don't even know
there's a timing thing on it you know I
mean it's just I just think if you're
listening to your instincts you'll
always be happy so time doesn't even
really matter you know what I mean
because you're not doing some [ __ ] that
you don't want to do you're doing the
things if you're doing the things you
want to do why wouldn't you be happy it
doesn't make sense not to be and that's
the thing is that people don't know what
they want to do and that's another
simple thing like first before you do
anything figure out what you want to do
if you would you really want to do you
know what I mean did you have that
vision when you started comedy of like
where you wanted to take your comedy
career yeah and you're living that yep
like for the most part I wanted to I
mean overall than anything I just wanted
to laugh and have a lot of fun okay and
as long as comedy is afforded me that
I'm on the right path you know what I
mean okay like when I was a kid I was
watching Magic Johnson like not just
play but in interviews if you'd laugh
and he'd be smiling my damn that guy's
having a lot of fun I would like to have
that amount of fun in my life and then
through comedy that's what I'm doing
like the people are hanging out with
late-night and diners we laugh we joke
we just we just be rolling you know what
I mean after a set and say doing comedy
and the people you meet are funny and
you're having a good ass time hey you
might not have all the money in the
world but what's better than having a
good time like for real like what is
like like such a good time you couldn't
even pay for this [ __ ] yeah yeah and
your time I hanging out with like the
Mount Olympus of comedy yeah you're
hanging out with the top comics in the
world yeah is there anything
you've learned from being around that
caliber of talent or any other like
lessons or just how they operate or how
they think that maybe you could share
with the audience just I know a lot of
the good people are honesty like the
funniest people the honesty has gotten
them you know they're bringing their
honesty off stage on stage has gotten
them to where they want to go you know
so it's different for everybody
especially like generations have changed
so it's like whatever's going on with
the new generation or newer generations
you know whatever just whatever you
follow instinctually like there's so
many different ways [ __ ] works
is like me saying what I picked up
doesn't even really always necessarily
apply to what's going on now even though
I'm in the now you know what I mean well
it could trigger it could trigger
whatever you learned may not apply
specifically but it may trigger another
like inspiration yeah I would just like
one the guys I hang out with like
Patrese and burr and Keith Robinson and
just other people they would just and
there's so many other day was just the
most successful ones of them they were
just honest about who they were like Jim
Norton is honest you know his comedy on
stage is just honest you know and then
my Dave Attell just works hard you know
it's just just keeps writing you know
and just keeps going so that's all
that's that's specifically what I've
learned
yeah well that's this has been an
awesome and taught us a lot here did you
enjoy it
no no no yeah yeah I feel like this
whole interview you were waiting for
that punchline you'll wait all day for
the good morning text like I just can't
wait to tell this kid I hated his dinner
yeah well you hadn't done that many
interviews so I was happy that you were
willing to sit down and like share the
time so maybe I can't even tell ya they
got a tag no I mean maybe
I will never even tell you yeah maybe
I'll not even let you release this yeah
but as we before we get out of here is
there anything else you want the world
to know uh special comes out in Comedy
Central midnight July 12 which is
technically July 13th but Friday night
July 12 midnight check it out and if you
don't see it then go to Comedy Central
check it out online follow me on
instagram at Ian Edwards comic and my
website it's kind of functional you know
with comedian calm yeah so go there you
know and just have fun enjoy his life
trust yourself boom that's do that's the
big lesson and hot breath the first
trust yourself trust your instincts here
put in the work though put your mind to
something and you can achieve it like
mr. Edwards here yeah
starting out in comedy he was like one
day I want to do a podcast in the lobby
of a hotel and now we made it sometimes
you you know you make you get
sidetracked doing things you don't want
to do this is the apple tree here on the
side of the bay this is the orange
everyone on the path well if you did
enjoy this episode you found it helpful
reach out to Ian personally let him know
that his time off his in path was
well-spent and you did learn a lot from
him because that is all we're trying to
do here in Opera that is just learn from
the most successful comedians in this
game so and this week you chose me and
we choked we took a side pat on the show
to interview yeah we took a little site
next week you'll be talking to some but
successful comedy this was really just
to get to Tosh later
Ian's the conduit to Tosh Joe Rogan so
guys just stay with us basically bear
with us yeah no dude I'm a fan man I
feel I found a fan they like not mad at
that at all you're right as a comedian
and watching your writing and just
seeing your success not only in the
writers room and then now we've really
inspired me is you're like I'm not gonna
take that 9 grand a week job because I
want stand-up to be like
my identity now it's like that's way
that's because I thought stand-up was my
identity but people just you know so now
you have to let them know no you know
what I mean
yeah baby that hasn't I mean you just
made that decision not long ago you know
it takes time like you said yeah it's
got a bake yeah yeah you know what's
gonna happen no trust me I know
especially I would they doing it yeah
especially after this sidebar so if you
did enjoy this please subscribe to the
YouTube channel hit us up on all of our
social media share this with people that
love Comi that's what we're doing here
so spread the message of comedy hot
breath podcast to the website if you
want to support us directly and get some
merch and support Ian Edwards and all of
his endeavors to making stand-up his new
identity oh yeah there you go
I like that would you for the hot breath
averse just look at them and let them
know who you are and why they should
listen to hot breath podcast my name is
Ian Edwards and listen to hot breath cuz
you might learn some [ __ ] not from this
episode but maybe for the other episodes
alright alright Ian Edwards thanks for a
hot breath man
[Music]
I breath